shake and bake shake and bake I'm I'm
just a hick in Canada okay no hey guys
i'm abby Sharpe welcome to Abby's
kitchen I am back for my wedding and
honeymoon I'm feeling totally refreshed
yet kind of still exhausted I've got a
lot of post wedding projects to finish
up including my HP passion project so if
you're just tuning in one of the things
I thought I'd do instead of giving all
my friends and family traditional
thank-you cards is create a little DIY
cookbooks using my trusty HP printer it
has been a wee bit hectic here after the
wedding I haven't had a whole lot of
time to do much of anything but the one
thing I haven't had to worry about is
picking up more printer ink to finish
off this - the project of mine I am
loving this new HP instant ink
subscription service that detects when
I'm running low on ink and then
automatically just sends me more to my
door plus instant ink estate we've got
50% on my ink bill this month so I've
really been able to keep this little DIY
cookbook under budget so I'm gonna put a
little healthy twist on another one of
my family's favorite recipes I want to
show you how this whole little DIY
cookbook thing is all coming together as
well we're gonna make a little gluten
free shake and bake because growing up
shake and bake was a total staple we
probably had it at least once a week so
I thought we would make it a little
healthier we've boost up the fiber and
we've used skinless boneless chicken
breast instead of what my mom would use
which is like skin on drumsticks plus I
know my sisters doctor has recommended
that she trial occlude free diet miss
inferred tummy troubles so we're gonna
be experimenting with some non
traditional flowers as well let's get to
it so first I'm gonna pulverize some
gluten free rolled oats in a food
processor until they reach a nice flower
like consistency
okay so now we can pop our oat flour
into our little resealable bag next I'm
going to add in our coconut flour which
is a lot higher in fiber and protein and
those healthy fats than your traditional
wheat flour so I really love that for a
breading like this and then we add all
of our spices we've got some smoked
paprika a little bit of poultry
seasoning some brown sugar just a touch
you don't really need that much some
onion powder garlic powder some dried
parsley and good amount of pepper and
some salt so I'm going to shake this all
up get our shake and bake mix ready in
with our breasts so this recipe is also
really great for you know pork or any
other kind of poultry like Turkey would
also work really great as well seal up
the baggie and we already shake can we
dance this can we put some music on I
want y'all at home to get in with this
all right let's do
gonna get a good workout now's your
chance so here's a little quick tip I
always like to preheat my baking sheet
in a 400 degree oven so that way the
second the chicken goes down get a nice
golden crispy bottom as well as a nice
golden top because nobody likes a soggy
bottom right and the other thing I like
to do is just grab them these little oil
atomizers with some extra virgin olive
oil inside that way you can use a really
good high-quality olive oil and then
just give it a little spritz on top just
to get a little bit of extra browning
okay so these are gonna go into a 400
degree oven for about 25 to 30 minutes
usually get nice and golden brown and
they reach an internal temperature of
about 165 Fahrenheit
so good mom you're never going to need
that box version again I think this is
gonna make the best last recipe in my
little pretty printed cookbook I cannot
wait to see my parents reactions to this
so guys if you liked what you saw be
sure to check out the other two videos
with recipes that are featured in this
little cookbook give me the thumbs up
big ones please leave me a comment below
with some of your family's favorite
recipes subscribe to the channel and
stay tuned for some of my family's
reactions